Sally Field you bring us an
extraordinary more in pieces there it is
it is out now by the way how beautiful
is that gorgeous
it's a little light reading well it's
not light reading we but it's a
fascinating story and you know there's
so many personal things in here yeah and
and I understand the urge to to figure
it out in your hand to write it down but
it is weird that then like y'all's like
me you can know it and you know people
will read this and know these things
about you yeah yeah what compelled you
to write it well um when my mother
passed away on my 65th birthday seven
years ago now I I thought that I had
done all the things that that you have
in your head you're supposed to do to
have those conversations and resolve
whatever you feel is unresolved it's to
this point and and yet when she was gone
I felt so deeply really just unsettled
an urgency about it like there was
something wrong like I would
something-something gang groaning on me
and I didn't know what it was and I
couldn't put the pieces together and I I
didn't know why I was feeling this way
and that was the beginning of it and I
knew it I had to find for myself what
this story was what put the pieces
together because I had drug around my
entire life boxes and boxes of
memorabilia from my life from for 40
years of letters and in my journals and
Lord knows memories and many times I had
never had the courage to read them I
have letters from my father from 35
years ago 40 years ago that he kept with
me didn't throw away but he never wanted
to know clearly what was in them because
I didn't feel I had this strength to
know so it was only in forcing myself to
learn a new crap I took seven years to
learn a new craft that I went into these
boxes of memorabilia that I read these
letters and at the same time I would
write oh my god okay this is what it
says and I would be shaking and
revealing and uncovering this
information that a simply
needed to know before I could ever move
on I would be 65 the rest of my life
until I was dwindling and gone yeah
but the story you tell one level it is
that your career because that threads
your life but you do as you say share
these stories you know being abused as a
child difficult relationships your
insecurities and I don't know if you'll
agree with this what I was really struck
was how important your work was it
wasn't just work that you found personal
strength and the characters you play
well it wasn't even that it was that
when I was 12 years old and I don't know
how you guys found your craft or Howard
why you even ended up there when I was
12 I was lucky enough to and in my
junior high I was lucky enough to have a
theater arts department and I was a you
know came from a sort of traumatic kind
of childhood and I had I had put myself
for survival and a sort of fog but when
I stepped on stage and it wasn't even a
stage it was a classroom with all the
chairs and and deaths pushed aside and
did my first scene and I was 12 and
seventh grade and it was from born
yesterday I couldn't have been more
wrong and but it was that some bell rang
and the fog cleared and something
electric like a spark happened inside me
and I was alive and I could hear my own
voice I was purely alive onstage with
that young man across from me and I
heard myself speak to myself and it was
the only time it had happened it was
just a flash and then I went back to not
knowing what to do with my hands and my
feet but my whole life long I have spent
you know trying to search after those
fireflies on the edges of my eyes which
is what led me through my entire life
who are you
I'm here long have you given more
speeches about this I mean because I
think it's it's very powerful what you
just said about MIT more speeches I've
been on the road with this book for two
months you want to buy a book
[Music]
you